my vision for Africa is I think we
should really really concentrate when a
youth because they use the sixty percent
on completion you know there are under
25 there 35 years so I think if we're
going to consider under the youth goin
back 2 2 to the schools to 22 high
school teaching them the financial
literacy teaching them are the tools you
know the intrapreneurship the
anti-corruption met that of our you
don't have to be corrupted to be
successful in life so you know we teach
the financial interest with it the Meyer
savings which is the mom checking
accounts intrapreneurship beginning I
think that's the future that's that's my
vision for Africa the next 10 years
interview we know all those feature we
teach them the leadership we go back we
talk to we talked to them about not
creating stuff like let's say let's say
someone says about population population
I don't like that maybe we should create
both you know we will start talking
about wealth creation for change